and don't get me wrong there are some
smart women out there but as a group as
a collective I'm like are we really
that smart and then I started thinking
about our decision making and I'm like
whenever we take over an industry we
just like ruin it it's so sad we'll like
base everything off our feelings and
like add an HR departments and like take
away the competitiveness of Industries
so it's like and then we'll do all these
woke hiring stuff so I'm like wow guys I
think they faked the IQ tests and tell
us that we're smarter when we're not
actually smarter I got because it just
doesn't make sense I'm like how the hell
are women smarter than men you just you
can't convince me of this this is not
this is not real they're Faking It